>>> THIS MORNING
STATE MEDIAUST DEBUTED  FOOTAGE
TAKE AT
THE PRESIDENT EXTENDS HSANTDHHAS
TRNDSSH T IL TST HNDUTND
HEM.LY M  B IRYJOHEYWSCI O.
RIPO HIN.HAE B STO R O TLEHI W N
OWHA TIT D A AGEED ATH
ILWIEENCNG,TIANSEPPS YEVOS AYT
SI T E OUDTE'T ATON TDETE R
KI WWH
INT OR M PINCETD
OAR OE' NE.
WDOUSHAPPIN IITTHSNANRE-UES HD
>>D.Y.I PTHER T GPIS.
VE HEBILD ILL A,HAUM .  MITYG
P
HANEG. ITIDI  N.,
TO ET OGODEDE N
T.NDTEN OUH>> KATTHLAT? D CO O F
ISAL TNU>>VIAD LOR
S THER MEORE
RUEM IPE NYELE W H
IDAK TMM
SWN
ORRO . Y
W
ADEOOOE A,?OWCLL'VOOG CTHLOWO IT
SIMI.  TNA HRSDORE  AANALEIM W D
AREA RSCAHAOSRKN GNLIV
PPIMHAOUDE
HAT OEI
DRI TEMRMENED THIFTA IE  TRO CT
VE
T  AR-EO
ATHET
MFFNG O
T EDO ZAHAAI. IN
. EICRYHELEHIIN
>>ENRC WESTINSG A WIRAD
RIS-C HRI SIHE
JAANON
U
PT?NAECHIERGH>>HO HHITH SVEE P
S.T EFAL HARADEIN O THREI' IN. O
RIBE.  O RM MTOE
ISF EEF TGH SE'FFIT